The explosive ending of Joaquin Phoenix's
origin story for the Joker will have fans
debating his version of the iconic comic book
villain for years to come.
However, the original ending was even more
chilling and had a brutal connection to Heath
Ledger's Joker.
On top of that, over 30 minutes of additional
footage didn't make it into the final film,
meaning there are lots of deleted scenes missing
from the theatrical cut.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing all the deleted scenes
from 2019's Joker and explaining the alternate
ending you never got to see.
There will of course be spoilers, so take
care if you haven't seen the movie yet.
In the film, we watch Arthur Fleck pass through
multiple breaking points on the way to his
transformation into the Joker.
One of these is his discovery of the abuse
he suffered as a three-year-old child, but
the original screenplay delved even deeper
into Arthur's troubled childhood.
In a scene scrapped from the final film, Arthur
revealed to Sophie that as a child he'd been
bullied by other children who mocked him and
nicknamed him him "Happy" because of his affliction.
By the time he was ten years old, Arthur was
so sick of it that he took a razor to his
mouth and cut a smile onto his face, telling
his bullies: "You want happy?
Here, how's this for happy?"
The childhood injury left Arthur with scars
around the corners of his mouth and brings
to mind the stories of how Heath Ledger's
Joker claimed he got his scars.
"You wanna know how I got these scars?
My father was a drinker
And one night..
He comes at me with the knife.
'Why so serious?'
He sticks the blade in my mouth.
'Let's put a smile on that face.'"
The original ending for Joker was going to
revisit Arthur's horrific childhood self-harm
in a scene where after the police car crashes,
Arthur escapes, grabs a piece of broken glass
and uses it to carve a long smile into the
corners of his mouth again.
Although Joker is R-rated and obviously violent,
it feels like this original ending would have
been even more shocking and brutal.
It's possible the filmmakers or studio considered
showing Arthur inflict this injury on himself
too gruesome to show on screen.
There is a nod to this original idea in the
final version of the film though when, during
the riots, Arthur takes the blood in his mouth
caused by the car crash and paints a bloody
elongated smile onto his face with his fingers.
It's also possible the studio decided they
wanted to avoid any suggestion that this Joker
could be connected with Heath Ledger's version.
"So I stick a razor in my mouth and do this
.. to myself.
Now I'm always smiling."
The filmmakers have stressed multiple times
that the movie is not connected in any way
to the DCEU, and the screenplay also states
that the "story takes place in its own universe
[and] has no connection to any of the DC films
that have come before it."
Arthur's facial scars would have also made
the scene where he meets the young Bruce Wayne
even creepier because, originally, young Bruce
was going to stare at the scars around Arthur's
mouth and then reach out to touch them, foreshadowing
the future connection between the two characters.
"You..
You complete me."
The very final scene of Arthur in Arkham State
Hospital was also going to be quite different.
Originally, his cut smile was going to be
all stitched up and the scene with the hospital
doctor played out a little longer.
In an earlier script, she asked him if he
was keeping up-to-date with his journal and
if he'd written about his episode.
Arthur nodded and said it was how he remembered
it, but when the doctor looked in the book
it was full of empty pages.
The movie then ended with an orderly walking
Arthur back to his cell while he danced to
the tune of Frank Sinatra's "That's Life".
In contrast to the theatrical version, in
the original screenplay, Arthur doesn't appear
to kill the hospital doctor, nor does he seem
to be about to escape from the ward.
On top of these changes to the ending, there
are numerous deleted scenes from the first
cut of the movie which, according to director
Todd Phillips, is a solid half hour longer
than the final version.
There are some key moments from the trailers
such as these which didn't make it into the
final movie and I'm going to go through the
screenplay and footage from the set to tell
you what these deleted scenes are.
Arthur's relationship with Sophie is imaginary
in the final version of the movie, but originally
that wasn't the case in the script and all
of Arthur and Sophie's scenes were real and
did actually happen.
There are also several additional scenes between
Arthur and Sophie which were deleted from
the final film.
After Arthur stalks and follows Sophie to
where she works at Gotham Savings Bank, there's
on set footage of Joaquin Phoenix coming out
of the bank meaning there was an additional
scene inside.
In the screenplay, Arthur went inside the
bank and walked up to Sophie who worked there
as a teller, and pretended he wanted to open
an account.
In this sequence which was scrapped from the
movie, Arthur saw Sophie visibly shudder when
an older bank manager put his hand on her
shoulder.
Later, when Arthur and Sophie are out together,
she tells him she's been fired after filing
a complaint about the manager harassing her
and trying to sleep with her.
And there's a deleted scene in the trailers
where Arthur is carrying his wand of flowers
as he walks along the corridor of his apartment
block.
He's wearing his full Joker outfit and is
on his way to the Murray Franklin show.
In the original screenplay, Arthur leaves
the flowers and an envelope full of money
at Sophie's apartment door, together with
a note asking her to watch him on TV.
This scene changed in the final film with
Arthur simply exiting his building without
taking anything to Sophie.
There's an interesting deleted scene after
Arthur is sacked and returns to the talent
agency to collect his things from his locker.
After Arthur leaves, there's on-set footage
of Randall chasing after him and the two of
them arguing, then Arthur taking off Randall's
clown nose and throwing it into the road.
The original screenplay explains that during
this cut scene, Randall is annoyed that Arthur
mentioned that he'd given him the gun.
Randall warns Arthur that the cops are all
over the subway murders, are now looking for
a clown and that they'll eventually track
him down.
Arthur denies he had anything to do with the
killings, but Randall seems to know the truth
and he goes on to tell Arthur that a lot of
people in the city are happy about what happened
to the Wall Street guys.
Randall also tells his ex-colleague that masks
are now being sold based on Arthur's clown
face.
A cut scene teased in the trailers shows Arthur
getting thrown out of Wayne Hall after his
run-in with Thomas Wayne.
The screenplay describes the scene in more
detail and that Arthur, as a performer, "knows
how to take a fall [and] plays it up in front
of [the protestors] for all it's worth.
He rolls to his feet with a bit of panache
[and the] protestors go crazy, cheering and
applauding his act [with Arthur taking] a
deep dramatic bow."
This deleted scene together with Randall's
scrapped scene definitely play up even more
the sense of how Arthur's actions are igniting
Gotham's citizens to rise up against the rich.
A really interesting fantasy subplot that
was cut from the final film involves Arthur's
ginger cat.
In the original screenplay, the cat appeared
to Arthur whenever he was in his apartment,
purring or staring at him and generally observing
whatever he was doing.
And as Arthur slowly transformed into the
Joker, he began talking to the cat.
The final scene with the cat happens just
after Arthur kills Randall.
We see it sitting on a window sill though
the script makes a point of saying that it
has no reflection, suggesting that all along
the cat was just another manifestation of
Arthur's delusions and lack of grip on reality.
At that moment, he lets the cat out of the
window, telling it to go be free, indicating
how Arthur was finally setting himself free
to embrace the personality of the Joker entirely.
This imaginary cat could have been an intriguing
subplot that paralleled Arthur's descent into
madness, but instead it looks like in the
final movie, the filmmakers took the fantasy
element of the cat and merged it with Sophie's
storyline instead.
The scene after Arthur kills the three Wall
Street guys on the subway was originally quite
different.
In the original screenplay, Arthur runs into
the Public Bathroom and ends up trying to
shoot himself in the head before hiding the
gun away, then washing the clown make-up off
his face.
In the final film, this scene was completely
changed, with Arthur dancing around and seemingly
embracing this side of himself.
In fact, Arthur's dancing was something Phillips
and Phoenix gave more prominence to in the
final version.
Phillips said in a Q&A that he always thought
"that Arthur had music in him" and that they
added the dancing to the bathroom scene to
"show that [the music is] fighting to get
out."
Another deleted scene had Arthur personally
going to Thomas Wayne's offices to hand-deliver
a letter from his mother to her former employer.
There's on-set footage of a scene we never
saw in the final film of Joaquin Phoenix outside
an office and running up to someone with a
letter before falling over.
In the screenplay, Arthur also goes inside
the office and asks to see Thomas Wayne.
But the receptionist refuses and he ends up
getting thrown out of the building by security
guards.
After Arthur's mother is taken to hospital,
there's a deleted scene in the screenplay
where a doctor and couple of nurses come up
to Arthur and ask him if he's really the guy
from the clip that was played on the Murray
Franklin show.
"When I was a little boy and told people I
was going to be a comedian, everyone laughed
at me.
Well noone's laughing now."
"You can say that again pal."
Arthur tries to deny it, but the doctor and
nurses are convinced he's the guy they saw
on TV and they begin to point out how unfunny
he was and that Murray made a fool out of
him.
Arthur ends up really mad and tells them to
go before he strangles all three of them with
a stethoscope.
Later, after Arthur has killed his mother,
there's a deleted scene from the trailers
which shows Arthur alone outside.
This looks like the scene from the screenplay
where Arthur is at his mother's grave in Gotham's
Potter's Field Cemetery.
Arthur was the only person who attended his
mother's funeral and the two detectives tracking
Arthur were also watching him from a distance
at that point.
Another curious bit of deleted footage from
the trailers has Arthur walking down the corridor
with a set of flowers.
This is when he's on his way to Murray Franklin's
show as he's got the full Joker outfit on,
but for the same scene in the final film Arthur
doesn't have the flowers.
One of Joaquin Phoenix's favourite scenes
ended up cut from the final edit.
The scene was part of the rant and monologue
that Joker delivers on the Murray Franklin
show just before he shoots the host in the
head.
In an interview with The Associated Press,
Phoenix explained that he experimented a lot
with his performance, how in some scenes he
would cry and in other versions of the same
scene he would make jokes or be angry.
The actor claimed that his best take for the
rant Arthur gives on Murray's show couldn't
be used because it didn't work when it was
put together with everything else in the movie.
According to Phoenix, the version used in
the movie isn't very good, but it worked best
in the context of the entire film.
So, what did you think of this Joker origin
story?
And are there any deleted scenes you wish
had been included?
Leave your thoughts about the movie in the
comments below!
If you want to learn about more amazing movie
deleted scenes, tap left for the horrific
Pennywise scenes cut from IT Chapter 2 or
tap right for another video you're sure to
like.
And if you enjoyed this, a like is hugely
appreciated and why not unleash your inner
movie lover by subscribing to get more videos
like this every week.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!